te la senti ragazzi mamma mia se però
così anche al 70 anni partiranno le
corde vocali che mi ricordo che quando
iniziava i primi video di fx vi parlo
del 2013
dovevo far vedere un inizio di un video
di è più vecchio ne apro uno a caso tipo
il cesso e malvagio i ragazzi benvenuto
e questo nuovo appello a tutti i ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo nuovo mamma mia non
riesco a farlo neanche se mi si impegna
pertanto guarda anche calmino po più
peso questo qua ecco lo vedono tutti
ragazzi benvenuti a questo nuovo video
porca vacca cosa ciò in gola però ben
importa giorni amoled giappone
mario spacca abbiamo mario spyphone nel
senso che gli state lusingando mamma mia
cosa non è diventato la ix che figo non
è vero non è vero
bello bellissimo ma che idea incredibile
non ci ho mai pensato a parola
bellissimo se facessi meno schifo a fare
gli spike ecco gli special tra tutti i
livelli ricorrenti di happy queste sono
stati sono imposti voli
ecco gli spikes phone sono quelli che ci
so cosa ci hanno ma solo un po più
difficili da fare non ho mai capito il
perché
haug mai le immagini si sa fa bene basta
che è stato e vabbè io non so neanche
bene e va beh mio dio sono morte questo
è difficile mamma mia ragazzi ma cosa
non è questo fatto veramente in crisi
marco demonio porco morto morto anche
porco però presenti e giampiero visto
che lo sfondo è grigio poi togliere in
grigio e mettere i teletubbies grazie
giampiero dobbiamo pregare in cinese che
sia solo questo livello porca vacca
eccolo non ci credo lepri ieri i cinesi
hanno funzionato molto bene planet
devils sarebbe tipo da fare con una chat
e orco demonio c'è un aereo che mi sa
che in qualche modo non mi regge infatti
aspetta un attimo che ti chiedo sto
fermo
potreste prestarmi un sedile va bene
così la mia sedia cosa fa mi aiuta nella
mia vita
un casino poi per cortesia bravo
io non volevo neanche prenderlo questo
aereo mi hanno costretto però devi
evitare ricordarmi le balle nel mentre
che lo stai precipitando l'ultima cosa
che dovresti fare proprio questa
l'attacco lampadario da quand'è che gli
aerei hanno i lampadari ragazzi
ma l'obiettivo è sopravvivere non ho
capito lo devo andare vado guidarvi do
io
se si gira dall'altra parte vado guidare
i ragazzi non so come ma ci provo a
posto sono andato guido io ma non c'è il
tipo non c'è l'hanno rigettato fuori ci
sono phineas e ferb
ma cosa centra la finale no no non ci
credo che un altro facciamone un altro
allora la wing sta lì a porca vacca
sarebbe troppo bello
brett tentativo numero 2 visto che prima
ho vinto al primo tentativo il secondo
lo rifacciamo dai bene ho dato già prova
di saper fare e basta
e incredibile che nella vita faccio
schifo con le donne però sono brava noi
boltro grazie grazie mille per aver
distribuito le capacità videoludiche in
questo modo 9 9 9 9 99 per cento
impossible
let's go ok ok è il terzo è quello buono
il terzo a partire dal quarto però
stavo stavo solo annusando il pavimento
non ti preoccupare edifici e schivare
gli arpioni lì in quel momento lì perché
e va beh è difficile scrivere di questo
secondo me ragazzi se io all'università
si insegna si sa che sarà un gran
professore non c'è una laurea ad honorem
per me
cos'è la smetta c'è la mia c'e la mina
indietro quando c'è la ragazzi quando
giocate è più di se c'è la mina dietro
sempre prendere la mira perché in
qualche modo mi ha scritto in inglese è
vlv me l'ha scritto in inglese le ha
trovate in inglese maledizione c'era un
muro di tua madre morta ecco cosa c'era
di difficile il suo livello cioè partono
gli anziani senza di te ne accorgi di
rom io ce l'ho fatta beh non è stato
così difficile
mamma mia oh quale capo il traguardo e
va bene a posto il film tutto a posto
suor trovi doverli uno perfetto
i due sono tipo di giochi qua sono tipo
quando fai a acquagym che praticamente
cosa succede ti rilassi e fai esercizio
fisico è la stessa cosa in realtà
ragazza però in tutto questo non riesco
a fini almeno l'esercizio fisico l'ho
finita
quanto la desideravi la morte così amico
mio perfetto non è vero
ok è rimasta lì va bene forse stavolta
ce la faccio ragazzi ok ne rimane solo
una ti prego c'è chi ci ha fatto le tesi
di laurea su happy meals non vorrei dire
altro o facciamo molto recenti purtroppo
sono sempre alle specialità perché in un
solo tentativo io dico mai un parkour
ma non è vero hanno fatto un parco di
minecraft suo happy meals va bene
scusatemi non ho bisogno di vedere rete
in secondo o io questo gioco non lo
capisco cosa diavolo è successo l'ho
preso non ci credo veramente dai semi
lanciavo subito se mi fossi lasciato
subito sarebbe stato incredibile fatto
una gran cosa ragazzi alla fine sono
caduto ma si chiude ma sto male ce lo
devo cliccare per chiuderlo ma mio dio
un genio che tela questo livello allora
non è chiude l'opera è arrivarci c'è un
macello suo livello di rating
mamma mia è veramente difficilissimo
arrivare su quella fare dice che avrà
una precisione millimetrica che col pogo
non ai no no ma impossibile ceva va
veramente abu certo livello
buono mourinho porco demonio porco
sempre in mezzo cadeau aspetta questo è
buono non è vero però sono aggrappato
varrà qualcosa non vale niente
mio dio
l'ho saltato bellamente proprio ne sono
fregato
c'è un zombie
a mio zio mi sono cagato penso che
saltasse addosso però va bene è
importante essere riusciti a falsa cosa
escape the box e poi una mamma mia che
testa non ho mai finito nella mia vita
neanche i vecchi tempi delle schede box
così in fretta ma i ragazzi di provare
un paio di miei livelli per la fine che
dite da un po che non lo faccio la cosa
mi sembra un po strano falli j può
vedere livelli fi james ce ne sono di
nuovi anche se non pensi che in us certi
che si mette ancora a livelli di alpini
se invece progetti ha i poteri frigino
morire ma mio dio quanto italiano questo
allora proviamo a fare parigi ei poteri
così curiosità se volete fare dei
livelli di me
sapete che ogni domenica shopping quindi
clicca più pedibus paolo a ok con il
boss palo e poi volare vai avanti nel
vuoto casini
ma cos'è come possibile se starò cosa
succede questo è successo è bruce power
vediamo in questo panorama che noi
vogliamo avanti bravo bravo effetto no
va bene c'è un potere che nuovi la
bottiglia telecinesi clicca bottiglia è
una televisione orientale da telecinesi
un po appena notato che lui si vede nel
collo per qualche strano motivo mi si
vede qualcosa attraverso la faccia
me ne sono accorta adesso ragazzi
perdonatemi adesso deve essere passato
porca vacca ma nel rapporto adesso
scusatemi
ho avuto un rischio in attivo per tutto
il tempo grazie avermi spiegato la
telecinesi lega cioè grazie veramente
non so come spiegarmelo sala fratello
non rompiscatole dinho che però è che
finché di lucida usa la telecinesi va
bene basta ora clicca il fratello di uk
se il soprano e più forte clicchiamo
schermo
mamma mia quanto è disimpegnato per fare
suo livello linear vulcano grazie bello
super fa vigente
28 giugno se volete farmi dei livelli
nuovi sapete che ci gioca siate creativi
troviamo l'ultimo facciamo un impossible
proprio il più vecchio il primo livello
di fa vj progetti sfido ha proprio fatto
però sicuro progenie mister pietro loro
già sapevano profili e mister pietro
dobbiamo studiare gli hi fi in modo poco
doloroso giusto un appello a san dana le
dovrebbe andar bene non saprei come
spiegarlo meglio questo ragazzo che ha
fatto sto livello tipo sei anni fa non
sto giocando con un po di ritardo amico
mio programma
[Musica]
thank you thank you no niente applausi
grazie mille mi sono accorte del green
screen un'ora dopo
spero mi sia piaciuto ragazzi questa è
la happy with ricordatevi se volete
farmi dei livelli fatemeli supportate mi
con il codice che lei per famiglie di
lusso happy meals non è vero non esiste
però supportano potete farlo fatevi
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciata
campanella per essere giocati sui video
vescono noi ce li ha ora preso il via
domenica prossima fuori altri e noi come
sempre belle ragazze
[Musica]